– Alan Walker, welcome!
You have spent a lot of
time on stage.
Do you sometimes get surprised
of your own success?
– The thought strikes me just by
watching these videoes.
During the pandemic, I’ve had a
lot of time to look back on
old pictures and stuff like that
it’s like: "Wow, have I
done all that?"
It feels weird
because everything has
happened so quickly,
but it’s been a lot of fun.
One of your first songs is
called "Fade".
– Yes.
– How old were you when you
made that song?
– 15-16 years old.
– It became a big hit.
And then I thought
can we get a masterclass
in how you build a song like that?
– Yes.
– So I asked you to bring your
computer.
And then I thought ...
You should know that she is a
DJ herself.
She has worked as a DJ.
Have you not?
– Yes, but I mean ...
– Yes, I have been a DJ,
but not with that kind
of audience.
– But you could ask relevant
questions.
– Absolutely! You could teach
me how to produce.
– How do you start to build
a song like that?
– We can start with the basics.
What I did when I started making
the song ...
I didn’t have any knowledge
of music production.
I had produced music for
two years.
I made the song based
on a gut feeling.
When I started making the song
I started with
a four hit chord progression.
Which is pretty standard
and you hear it in a lot
of top songs nowadays.
Something else I have
found out when making
is to not have the
song in 128 bpm
which is a high tempo and
very common.
– Now you’re too technical.
128 bpm, what is that?
– Beats per minute.
– So, the rhythm?
– Yes.
I decided to do something
different with the song
and slow down the tempo.
I turned the tempo down
to 90 bpm and found out
that you could hear the melodies
and the layers better,
I thought that sounded beautful.
– Let us hear the start of
the song.
– Go into character.
– It’s very simple.
From the start of the song to
the drop, its the same melody.
– Do you see how
easy it is, Fredrik?
– You make it seem very easy.
– The most important thing
for me in the song
is that the melody tells
a story throughout the song.
– So that’s what you’re adding?
– Now it’s just the same
melody over and over again,
but it builds up.
– And there it becomes "Fade".
– That’s the drop,
which is basically the chorus,
since it’s an instrumental song.
– What fascinates me, is that
today there are probably
right now a lot of people
with great equipment
trying to create songs
like this.
And then you create a song
by using these four chords, that
have been used many times before.
It’s like Picasso painting
a dog,
it becomes perfect
and you want to you hear it.
– Then you do some small
changes.
Let’s hear it now and
people will recognize it.
– Yes it will play on
the speakers, I think.
– How many times has this
been played?
It’s one of YouTube’s most
streamed songs.
– I have no idea.
– Billions of streams.
– It must be hard to hear
your own song
and not be able to dance,
but with five people sitting
like this.
– You learned to play the
piano after becoming world-renowned.
– Yes.
– Why did you do that?
– When I could make all these
different melodies,
I felt it wasn’t right.
that I could make beautiful
melodies and songs,
but couldn’t play them
on the piano.
That was my motivation.
– How did you learn
to play the piano?
– I watched YouTube.